[Music]
hey everyone its Joe next year so we're
going to do something really crazy today
okay I want to challenge you to complete
10,000 squats in 30 days so for the next
30 days we want to complete 335 squats
every single day by the end of the 30
days you will feel your leg muscles your
bum muscles and you will get a tone and
tighter looking lower body and core as
well so get your body warmed up and
let's start squatting there will be a
different variations of squad okay so
let's start with as a basic squat so for
the busy squad we want to aim for 50
repetitions
okay extend sugar with a pot to it point
the forward and let's go down and always
remember to keep your chest up back
straight okay
so nice and deep and get your butt
muscles and give your legs and really go
down nice take it easy this is only the
side so this is also part of your warmup
to really get your lik muscle going and
just get your blood flowing in your body
good
always remember to push up with your
heels okay good
keep going it's not a matter of rushing
the workout it's a matter of getting a
good deep squat good huh 335 every
single day nice the to the chest up do
not ever hunch forward okay you're not
doing this chest up look straight ahead
push your butt back but should always be
back so your knees should not go over
your toes keep going fixing more and
after this we want to stay low and get
into small squat pulses ten more okay
still on your basic squat so you can
keep your hand in the middle if you want
to last five four three two and one and
I'll stay low 13 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 2 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 20 3 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 13 good all the way up let's challenge
a little bit more squat jump ok 15 times
then let's go 1 2 good same thing good
squat position 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 plus 5
more 1 2 3 4 5
good now shake it out a little bit okay
that was something like your first set
the second set we want to go into create
squat that means I want you to stand
white turrets pointed out these points
at us get down into a white sumo squat
ok so let's do 30 for it 3 good keep
going so these points it out to your
inner thighs working nice keep squatting
push your butt back ok chest up as well
dig deep and really for your inner
thighs working again you can place your
hands on your waist if you want to so
just keep them in the center halfway
there
good keep squatting low ten more nine
eight seven six five four plus three
last two last one and now say low squat
pulses one two three four five six seven
four nine 10 - 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 20 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 nice very thin can you see the
birds right let's challenge ourselves
and get into narrow to wide squat okay
so let's start white let's go 1
2:15 three four good five six seven
eight nine ten squat low one two three
four five good job shake it out you're
halfway there okay stay with me
give your thighs a huge pad all right to
your bum muscles working and now get
into narrow squat same thing let's start
with thirteen normal narrow squat ready
toes pointed forward let's go one two
good again no matter how wide you go
always remember push your butt back okay
even when you're drink nurse what chest
all right your form is extremely
important keep squatting you're doing
really really good fifteen laughs
halfway there
remember to breathe in and breathe out
okay
ten nine and no the next one eight seven
six five four three two one all right
stay low 30 small narrow squat houses
let's go one two three four keep it
small 6 7 8 9 10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 20
lap 10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
so the oh my gosh all right right now we
want to get into 30 low squat down okay
so stand sure with the past toes pointed
forward say low and give me small jump
so ok forward 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 push
yourself
three four five six seven eight nine
twenty three [ __ ] four five six seven
eight nine thirty Oh shake it out shake
it out
all right Google likes a short break and
one final shot sequence alright so let's
start with squat with side leg raise
okay so stand shoulder width apart squat
down wake up
good so you will be engaging the outer
side good keep going keep your body
straight okay
find your balance nice let's straight
ahead and just gently raise your leg to
the side this is also sort of like a
nice relaxing break for a while
good keep going whoa almost halfway
there keep squatting remember do not
cheat okay go deep fifteen that go deep
dig deep find the strength within you
all right every time you clear the pain
that is your muscle your leg muscles
getting stronger and more nine eight
seven up six whoa stay with me
five four more four three last two most
stay strong two last one and shake it up
next challenge okay 180 degree
rotational squat so I want you to start
by facing to your left
okay so we want to hop and face to the
opposite side okay only 15 times ready
let's go one two good
three four five
do the burn six
seven eight nine ten star five builder
burner
during your part two three four five
whoa-ah and now the last workout you
have done three hundred squats and the
final one is to hold it for 30 seconds
okay it's just a squat hole give you a
best shot
are you ready let's get down and start
now within don't rush your breathing
find your sense of gravity
this isn't your breath calm yourself
down okay and just gently beside you see
your sweat dripping
halfway there you're almost there
you have ten seconds left and you're
done okay based on you are strong your
legs on strong four three two one and
that one 335 squats
give it a good shake well done guys
so that was 335 squats okay so for the
next 30 days I want you to challenge and
push yourself to do this workout every
single day yes it might be difficult to
begin with you will struggle the first
few days but keep pushing yourself pause
the video when you need to and get back
into the workout the goal is to complete
this exercise and at the end of 30 days
I can assure you you will be so proud of
yourself
alright so share your progress with me
tag me at your NFL official hashtag
Jason active because I want to be part
of your squad journey okay like this
video subscribe to my youtube channel
share this video with a friend and get
them to squirt with you out of that